hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to reveal
exactly how i use bridging finance
to recycle all of my money in every
property deal that i do
so i put my money in i pull my money out
of the deal
effectively leaving me with a free house
this is a strategy that i've been doing
for many many years
i've helped hundreds of people to do the
same and i'm going to tell you in this
video exactly how i do it so please do
me a massive favor
smash the like button drop a comment
below if you find this video helpful
and also make sure that you are
subscribed and turn the notification
bell on so you never miss a video
now let me just give you a a case study
right now okay
now i'm going to keep the math simple
i'm going to keep the numbers really
round
at 100 000 pounds just so that you're
able to follow a little bit easier but
imagine
that i want to buy a house to rent out
and i want a 100 000 pound house
and i want to rent it out and i want it
to be nice i want to have a nice tenant
that's what i want
most people in my situation would say
well if i want 100
house i need to get a mortgage 75
loan to value and i'll put my deposit
down of 25
that's standard for buy to let so i need
25 grand
to buy 100 house i leave my 25 grand in
i get my rent and i hope that the
property goes up in value which you
probably will over time
fine the problem with that is if you
want to buy
lots of houses you need to keep saving
up lots of 25 grams
and who can keep saving lots of 25 grams
unless you happen to have a really high
cash flowing business
and even even then you shouldn't do it
it's not smart you'd be better off to
put your money in pull your money out
and recycle it over and over using
bridging finance which i'm going to tell
you how to do in this video
so how do you do that well instead of
finding a pretty house
that's in nice condition for 100 grand
and of course it could be 200 grand it
could be a million
the figures the the figures are the same
the formulas are the same but
again let's say 100 grams what i'll do
instead is i'll find a property
that's the 100 grand house but it's run
down it's dirty
it's got a problem it's got no kitchen
no bathroom you can't get a mortgage on
it
horrible house but it has potential to
be like the 100 grand house
but because it's so run down and so
horrible you agreed to buy it for 50 000
pounds
so you buy it for 50 000 pounds and
you've only got 25 grand there so what
do you do when instead of getting a
mortgage
you get a bridging loan so you buy it
for 50 grand
you put down your 25 000 pounds and the
remaining 25 000 pounds
you get bridging finance to buy it
you then refurb the house
and you spend maybe 25 000 pounds in
this example
fixing it up getting new kitchen new
bathroom
new boiler new windows you fix up the
house
and where do you get that 25 grand from
you use
bridging finance to get the 25 000 pound
reverb done
so now you've put twenty five thousand
pound of your own money and you've
borrowed fifty thousand pounds
from bridging finance companies to get
the house
up to scratch now the house is like the
hundred grand house
but you have got it for 75 grand in
total because you've had to do some work
you've had to do some negotiations
you've got to see the vision
but now the house is worth 100.
so what do you do you go and approach a
mortgage
lending company and you say can i please
borrow
75 000 pounds against this
100 000 pound house the one next door
is worth hundred and this is just the
same so you borrow 75 000 pounds
from a mortgage lender and you use that
75 000 pounds
to firstly pay off the bridging finance
which will be 50 000 pounds
and pay back yourself
so you're paying yourself back so when
you're buying houses and you're putting
down deposits
you're paying yourself back from the
mortgage companies
once you fix the properties up and that
is how you recycle your money and when
you get your 25 grand back what are you
going to do you're going to do it again
and then you're going to get your 25
grand we're going to do it again and
you're going to keep going you're going
to get
going and that's how when i started when
i was 17 years old
from working class background with
nothing i didn't have any money
i i had to get 100 borrowed money but i
just snowballed and snowballed and
snowballed and saved my rents and saved
my rents and snowballed and snowballed
that's why now i've got a multi-million
pound property portfolio at age 29
because i used this strategy and you can
do the exact same thing now maybe you're
thinking
but samuel isn't it really risky what
happens if the property doesn't value up
you do all this work and then the
property gets down valued that's why
before you buy the property
you do diligence to make sure that there
are houses in the street that are worth
a hundred thousand pounds
so you can do a like for like comparison
so that you know what the donut value is
going to be
maybe thinking samuel what about what
about bridging finance is it hard to get
bridging finance
no it's not in fact even if you've got
bad
credit the bridging finance companies
don't care even if they don't care about
you they care about
the property so if you get good at
finding the properties
the bridging finance comes now listen
i'm not a financial advisor so of course
you know i want you to take all this
information and i want you to start
being creative and then go and get the
relevant advice from the
from the financial advisors from the
mortgage lenders
but all i'm doing is teaching you what
i've done and what i do and what i've
trained
thousands of people to do so they care
about
the house you might be thinking but
saying isn't bridging finance really
expensive
well it is typically they might charge
up
between half a percent and one and a
half percent a month
so if they're charging say one percent a
month which is pretty standard but
on the expensive side they're charging
one percent a month
that's expensive but
you're not going to have this for many
months the refurb is only going to take
three to six months
so you have to fax this into your costs
of course same as you're going to have
legal fees
but the point is you're going to have
that if you buy a house regardless
whenever you buy a house you're going to
have to pay legal fees
i mean taxes will be cheaper when you do
this strategy
because when you buy a property that's
unmortgageable you don't pay stamp duty
tax
so there's so many advantages and i want
to keep this
video brief because there's so much i
could go into you might be thinking
but what happens if the refurb goes over
25
000 pounds then you're stuffed well
again this takes
skill i wouldn't recommend just having a
bash this is a profession
so when people tell me samuel you can
just learn everything online for free
why do you run courses
by the way most of my courses are free
by the way in fact i run a property
investors crash course which is free i
welcome you to come
and attend i do a lot of training for
free but
you've got to take this seriously you've
got to put the hours in you've got to
study because this is
if you want if you want to start
recycling your cash on bridging finance
companies
and growing up a multi-million pound
portfolio i would suggest that you
sharpen the axe
and what i mean by that is you sharpen
your knowledge before you start going
doing it
for sure i mean the refurb could go over
that's why you need to make sure that
you get you've got good builders you've
got a good power team
in place you know how to find the deals
so
if you found this video helpful let me
know if you want to join me at the
property investors crash course i'll
leave a link in the description below
i also think you might find this video
really helpful where i summarize the buy
refurbished refinance strategy
so i'll see you at the property
investors crash course i'll leave a link
in the description get yourself booked
on and also
subscribe right here so you don't miss a
future video thanks
you